Transcriber:
When I was 12, I had a dream
to tell one million young people
that it is possible to close the gap
between how learning should feel like
and how it actually feels.
All my friends went to school
out of pressure to compete
in gaining the highest grades,
which leads to depending
their self-worth on numbers,
normalizing cheating and hating school.
I had this mission
because I wanted young people
to fight for our right
to have an education
that encourages us to learn
out of internal curiosity
instead of external pressure,
and one that feels rewarding, fun,
self-fulfilling and collaborative.
So I thought if I could talk
in front of a thousand people at a time,
I would just need to do
that a thousand times
and then I would reach
a million people, right?
Until I realized that I could reach
millions of people all at once online.
For me, realizing that
felt like finding a superpower.
That's when I started my journey
as an educational content creator
and changemaker.
So I created videos that challenge
students to find the subjects
they are curious and passionate about,
provided tips on making learning fun
and demonstrated how technology
could transform how we learn
and help us reach our fullest potentials.
Since then, my videos on YouTube have been
viewed more than 55 million times.
Plus, I've helped create social activism
through my online work,
starting online movements
that encourage young people
to speak up about
their own concerns in education
and share how they take
action to solve them.
I also became more involved
with the online community of UNICEF
and U-Report Indonesia.
As a U-Report ambassador,
I initiated large projects
and invited other changemakers
to join forces.
For example, I coordinated
a workshop on digital tools
and other 21st century skills
to help build the capacity
of hundreds of young people.
I've had so many wonderful opportunities
through UNICEF and U-Report
and my own YouTube channel
to try to positively
shape the world for the better.
But I also discovered some downsides.
The downsides that I’m afraid
too many young people have experienced
from being online.
If you have a strong voice online,
especially as a young person
and especially as someone
trying to make change in the world,
there is definitely pushback.
It's like by giving advice,
people think you're putting
yourself on a pedestal,
and so people try to knock you down.
For instance, one of the things
I've talked about a lot
is the possibility for Indonesian students
to study abroad.
Of course, that meant people
expected me to prove it was possible
by studying abroad myself,
and I really wanted to.
Although I got into
my dream university in Canada,
I didn't get the scholarship
I needed to afford attending.
And when people kept
posting online, saying things like,
"Why are you not in Canada?
That's why you shouldn't
be dreaming too high,"
I felt embarrassed
and so insecure about myself.
Whether you have one follower
on social media or one million,
you've probably known this feeling.
Or maybe you don't post
the truth about your life
because you're afraid to be judged.
I think the first part of the solution
comes from within.
It starts with self-awareness.
When we feel pressured
by a certain expectation
imposed by others,
it usually indicates
that that same expectation
is also coming from within us.
I was disappointed in myself and sad
that I couldn't live up
to my own expectations.
I realized that I expected myself
to be an excellent role model
who could prove
that everything is possible,
which is the actual source of why I felt
this massive pressure in the first place.
The other part we need to work on
inside ourselves is self-acceptance,
which means embracing
our flaws and failures
as important parts of what makes us human.
Through time, I was able to accept
that I am allowed to make mistakes,
that the only people who don't fail
are the people who don't try.
And I was trying to do great things,
so, of course, I would face
some challenges, right?
I think if we all find some self-awareness
and self-acceptance,
then we can adjust.
It is so, so important
to adjust our expectations
to be more aligned and realistic
to our own current situation.
So instead of expecting myself
to prove everything is possible,
now I focus more on proving that we can
always learn from our failures
and use what we've learned
to help other people.
But let's be clear, we can't address
the hardships of social media,
especially things like cyberbullying,
with individual resilience alone.
Because worldwide,
more than one-third of young people
have reported experiencing
cyberbullying online.
And so the other thing we must do
is treat each other better in social media
and online communities in general.
After all, I've been attacked,
criticized and harassed even when I posted
things out of good intentions.
In some cases, I've received some
very extreme and disturbing messages.
Being bullied online
feels especially humiliating
because of the scale:
more people attacking you online
than you even know in real life.
And this happens to everyone
in some way online,
not just to people with big followings.
So I really think if we want
better online spaces,
we have to each play a role
in creating them
by committing to treat each other
with kindness and respect,
even when we disagree.
So before we leave a comment,
we should always ask ourselves:
How would I feel if I were
the one receiving this comment?
And if you are being harassed
or bullied online or offline,
please, please, please
ask for help and support.
Being resilient does not mean
we have to face things alone.
We could be vulnerable at the same time,
reaching out and talking
to trusted people
like our parents, best friends,
teachers or even psychologists.
In my case, I told my parents
what I was going through,
and they kept me strong in resisting
the urge to quit social media.
I also went to a psychologist to help me
overcome the mental health issues
I faced due to cyberbullying.
She suggested that I take
a break from social media,
to ground myself instead
of quitting for good,
and that was actually great advice.
It helped me gain
some important perspective.
To be sure, there are
bigger dynamics at play
that require the leadership
of social media platforms
and the government
to make sure we're
as safe as possible online,
especially in the case of kids.
These are complex issues,
and while we can work as individuals
to be more resilient
and as communities to be more kind
and careful with each other,
systemic problems
ultimately need systemic solutions.
These technologies are our future,
and we need to make sure
that future is healthy and safe for us.
In the end, for me,
when I took a break from social media,
it helped me to really reflect
on why I do this,
why I use online tools
to educate and engage my peers.
And I realized my motivation
used to be extrinsic,
wanting people to be helped
and be inspired.
I hadn't really meant to,
but by posting content for other people,
I was depending my sense of impact
and even self-worth
to what other people
thought or said about me.
But now I've realized my motivation
is and should always be intrinsic,
wanting to try my best
in sharing what I've learned
because it gives me
fulfillment and purpose.
There is a difference.
Extrinsic motivations depend on results
that are out of our control
while intrinsic motivations
depend on things we could do
that are under our control.
We will be less likely
to take external feedback to heart
if we do things online
out of intrinsic motivations.
What we do online and offline,
we should do simply because
we believe it is the right thing to do.
So I have a question for you.
What’s your personal mission
for being on social media,
and what will you do to fight for it?
I would love to see more young people
becoming catalysts of change
by harnessing the power of social media --
and do so not by sacrificing
our mental health
but by being equipped
with self-sustaining tools
and engaging on platforms
that are nurturing and strengthening
for individuals and our world.
I may not be going to Canada,
but I am going to the future.
No matter what.
Technology is my generation's tool
to fight for the future we want to see.
It should help us, not hurt us.
Thank you.